thank you all for coming
um I'm very happy to see you um I am
delighted to be introducing my colleague
from Ukraine
um who has come here
um from the other side of the ocean it's
by difficult circumstances
um she comes to us originally from
donets but in the meantime from the
Ukrainian Catholic University and Louise
and from the European University and we
are very not in Germany
um she is a historian and sociologist
who combines those methods in her work
she has been working now and I think for
the past several years or at least since
we met in Vienna a few years ago on this
issue of refugees and internally
displaced persons and I think most of
you may know and Jenny is not in the
room otherwise he should really
introduce this topic
um so when the war in the dombas began
in 2014
it created a situation in which not only
were people being slaughtered and even
before this full-scale Invasion began
um since 15
000 people had died I could have that
number wrong and between a million and a
half and two million internally
displaced persons and that's a category
that refers to people who became
refugees in their own country
so domestic refugees so Ukrainian
residents of the Damas
um you know this
post-industrial mining region the Far
East of Ukraine where the war was
concentrated who were forced to flee
their homes and go into other parts of
Ukraine
um so it's conceptually politically
legally sociologically
um you know it's uh it's a very
interesting situation it's a very
painful situation
um it's a kind of agonizing situation
um and Oksana has been quite heroic in
both being a participant an observer in
those events and continuing her research
despite the most gruesome circumstances
um I will not take up any more time I
just wanted to give those of you who
don't work on Ukraine in particular that
context of internally displaced persons
I know a lot of you have experience
thinking about and working with refugees
and what does it mean when you have
refugees who are are are in their own
country but they are homeless and
displaced what does that mean for their
legal status
um and what does their what does that
mean for their lives
um with that I will turn you over to
Professor Michaela and thank you so much
for coming
thank you thank you so very much for
this introductions and first of all I
would like to say that I'm grateful for
everything to be here it's a pretty much
I've understand it so it's a privilege
to be in this wonderful and safe space
at the time when people in Ukraine are
living under the scale Russian language
today I will talk about the ordinary
people and the extreme life conditions
and uh my main focus was internal and
thank you very much for this
introduction I really talk about
refugees in their own country it's a
very good formula to describe this
situation but we are talk about
internally displaced person in this case
and a little bit I say about external
Force migration from Ukraine in this
time from what on territories in Ukraine
and what is very important for me and to
start with you to talk about this that
in my presentation I will talk about the
experience of forced displacement of
residents from the water and territories
of Ukraine after 2014 and before the
start of full-scale aggression ability
rate on the 24th of February 2022 why
it's so important for me because now we
have a complete period it's one stage
it's one stage which have a date will
start and day of the end and we are
talking about this period and try to
understand what lessons we we uh um from
this time
what took place in Ukraine from Spring
2015 to 24th of February 2022 and today
because they fight as a first phase of
Russian aggression against Ukraine uh
the outbreak of full-scale War marked at
the beginning of the radically new phase
which uh entailed a number of changes in
ukrainians it's another very important
point from me because we see how this
events push Ukrainian Society to do
something absolutely new however this
change largely took shape and manifested
themselves during this first fail phase
of Russian aggression what are the main
developments and Trends I'm referring to
while in 2014 we spoke consciously about
the formation of a political Iranian
Nation today ukrainians as a political
Nation are showing themselves quite
clearly my separate research devoted to
a study this Dynamic of Ukrainian
national identity and I see this process
as it's very very complicated processes
for foreign
citizens but this understanding of
citizenship still very problematic from
the point of view of current situation
in Ukraine but it's a separate topic
very interesting topic and uh we try to
study the experiment of citizenship from
the point of view of ordinary situation
citizenship from the hierarchical
citizenship from the emotional
citizenship and all all these give us a
very interesting information how it's
really uh is uh now in Ukraine the
country is experienced rapidization even
by air the Ukrainian language is
perceived not only as a language of
communication but also as a way of
distancing and protecting ourselves from
the aggression it's absolutely new
function of the language in the country
according to the latest results of
service by the key of International
Institute of Sociology so please maybe
you know this institution it's very good
physiological institution in Ukraine
despite the horrors of this war 70
percent of ukrainians are hopeful about
the future it's very absolutely
incredible excuse dude incredible
incredible results the next important
moment is first way of Russian
aggression was indeed a very strong
Catalyst for volunteerism in Ukraine if
before their participation in civil
Organization for a long period of time
was kept on the level of 11 14
BBC a completely different situation
according to the survey conducted by
sociological group of radio in March
2022 more than 80 percent of respondents
indicated that they helped to defend
Ukraine in one form when asked 80
percent yes
we've got 39 persons help people and the
Army as volunteers a 37 percent help
financially 18 percent they bought in
informational resistance 12 continue
working in the critical infrastructure
and only 19 percent of these respondents
indicated that they did not have the
opportunity to participate in volunteer
activity there are slightly more elderly
people in this group but even in this
group there are many people who
participate in volunteer activities
you don't seem that we now have
everything that 30 years of Ukrainian
Independence have discussed what is the
experience behind it all these marks the
civilization in the Ukraine during and
after year am I done and in the time of
the first payoff Russian aggression
against Ukraine from 2014 to 2022
extremely important to study and now I
start making Temptations
no no
one second
on this slide you can see a titles of
and briefly from a very brief
information about our main service in
this time as you can see it's really
um many of research I will not describe
all these studies in detail because we
have no time for these only the one
important moment we have had the
opportunity to collect data every year
from from the beginning from 2014 and uh
to 2018. in most cases it was a
qualitative method uh we conducted
in-depth interview with different group
of people affected by the war
and uh
start our conversation about
displacement by giving a little context
from the uh 20th of February 2014 to the
21st of February 2022 uh as I said
before its dates of the first day of
Russian aggression against Ukraine
within the space of Russian aggression
we see two separate cases that give us
significantly first the soft also called
gluteness without use weapon occupation
of Crimea Peninsula subsequently led to
its annexation and incorporation to the
Russian Federation as a separate federal
district in this case we have six
skilled people and 10 disappear and
second the Russian invasion of parts of
the Nets and Logan's creation are
compiled by a simulated internal civil
conflict and a referendum so it's so
important now because now we see the
repeating of the such technology in
Ukraine uh but in other occupied
territories uh and um
all of this led to formation of by the
state entities uh so-called donate
people
Republicans people Republic on these
territories terminology is other issue
very important I hope after my
presentation we come back to all these
uh terms which I used from my point of
view it's made a big issue for all
researchers for example if you conduct a
research and involve your participants
which are representatives from the both
side of the conflict it's very important
to have a good language setting how to
talk with people what terminology to use
it's absolutely impossible to talk with
people who live on the Ukrainian control
territory using for example DPR
Etc et cetera absolutely impossible to
talk with people who live on occupied
territory using this terminology of
occupied territory and why it's a very
big issue for researchers how to prepare
these tools which are very different and
how to combine them the this information
and make a conclusion if you ask about
something different because these people
live in different realities but then
I came back to the second second case in
this case as you can see we have uh so
many uh victims here uh it's
near 44 or more than 44 laws that's
recorded at all as you can see of those
more than 13
000 killed and uh more than 30
000 wounded 23 and 25 percent of these
losses were civilians we usually have a
problem with calculating with a number
of uh victims in this case and they
still have this problem why we are using
a different number when they talk about
the situation which I describes the Sikh
uh as you can see on the next slide uh
most civilian deaths secured in 2014
2015 during the active phase of
hostilities
this scheme clearly illustrates the
dubiousness of Russian Essences about
the need to protect the so-called people
of donbass it's uh it's next very
important combination of words which
have a very important sense uh it's a
part of Russian propaganda and they try
to construct these Community people of
donbos such a community has never
existed in Ukraine moreover at the level
of ordinary people we have reported
active attempt to deconstruct this
cliche of Russian propaganda many of our
interviews but let's come back to this
necessity to understand the specific of
force displacement in this stage and the
difference in the condition of forced
migration from Crimea and the occupy
in this so-called bloodless occupation
of Premium Peninsula people face
pressure and Street primarily because of
their Pro Ukrainian stems the white
French was discriminatory practices
applied to people who had pro-ukranian
positions caused their predication
the residents of the netsk and lugansk
region fled the world the fourth
implication was caused by a direct
threed to the life during the deployment
of military actions it's a very big
difference between these two contexts
accordingly they had very different
perception of the situation and did not
always have a pro Ukrainian stats but
the problem and what's the problem of
perception of this to do in Ukrainian
Society but not only these uh very
important role play played a state
rhetoric what they mean in Ukraine this
situation before the issue and the war
in 2018 about this situation because the
situation officially
anti-terroristic operation only after
2018 we start talking about war and
occupation it's very important for
understanding this context because
people who are
will internally displaced person have
not a clear sentences and have not a
clear understanding way from why they
come to other part of the country Etc
in the following slide you can see the
dynamic of registered idps in Ukraine
before the outbreak of full-scale work
to show you this Dynamic I have used a
good visualization from the publication
linked to on the slide but in Ukraine
all this data is public and available
our own website of Ministry of social
policy of Ukraine however colleagues
have visualized this dynamic in very
good way this is the number of
registered idps in Ukraine remains
relatively stable of this first higher
relocation compared to 2015 the active
combat phase in the following years we
see a slight decrease in the number of
registered idps and there are various
reasons behind this decrease in number
of IDP first of all this natural best of
many people because many people of
retirement age elderly people who
push to flow because of support then
it's a purchase of private Flags in
Ukraine it's very important moment in
Ukraine people and this case get a new
registration and lose their IDP status
then its pictures IDP have been removed
from the database of the series of
charts stage checks which removed some
part of the idps and some idps continued
their displacement and left for other
countries and some people have turned to
the occupied territories because of
financial difficulties in Ukraine mainly
due to problems is ranging accommodation
and employment
recruitful combination for many idps
because for rent in the house you need
to have a work if you have not work you
have money for 18 costs and this
combination was very important for many
people when they decide to return to the
occupied territory and there is another
important point understanding the scale
of internal displays during our first
interview in 2014 2015 we identified
that up to one sort IDP are avoiding
official registration for various
reasons these practices was more
pronounced among young idps who describe
their motives for avoiding registration
as both a reluctance to pass on their
problems to the state and a desire to
avoid stigmatization
and among the welfare part of idps who
were able to quickly passage your
housing in the control part of Ukraine
and change their registration
on this slide on the map uh to the left
uh you can see the location of
officially registered idps before the
full-scale Russian aggression as you can
see most of the displaced persons tried
to settle close to their homes in the
occupied statements the next conference
complex leaders in the number of idps
was due to Keith's attractiveness for
idps as the capital were all the key
stage structure are located
the choice in favor of Kiev was
rationally based on the fact that it put
idps close to the governmental
structures providing assists this
shouldered the distance and accelerated
the process of solving many problems and
then you see another line of regions
here on this map it's a carcube nepro
and the Collision which are also located
in the eastern and Southeastern part of
Ukraine in this case people who have
been affected by the work would resettle
in territories that remained under the
control of the Ukrainian government and
as close as possible to where they used
to live the other moment very important
for many of those people it's uh mostly
Russian speaking
on the right hand side of the slide you
see a visualization of displacement
taking place in the face of full-scale
Oppression aggression in 2022 the
situation is radically different most of
the idps have tried to move as far away
from the armed conflict Zone as possible
you see this difference between these
two situations between these two maps
another interesting detail because
apparently if we look at the settlement
map of idps in terms of their social
demographic parameters in 2015 the
United Nations higher Commissioners for
refugees published the map showing not
only the total number of idps by obelis
but also data on the proportion of
different groups of forced migrants such
as pensioners working age adults
children and disabled
here too we see an interesting pattern
among those registered as close as
possible to the dividing line pensioners
are the most numbers
this is another manifestation of the
problem of counting the real number of
idps in Ukraine after starting the first
day of Russian aggression in 2014 a
significant number of pensioners
registered close to the demarcation
lines but most spent most of their time
in their homes in the occupied territory
due to financial difficulties and the
absence of a systematic policy of State
support they came to Ukraine to undergo
identification procedure which remained
compulsory and regular every few months
for pension year before the pandemic
the situation changed dramatically with
their own set of the covid-19 pandemic
well before the pandemic there were
about a million monthly Crossing in both
directions very good sources uh where
it's a good app which shows you uh in
the dynamic of this data
and uh well before the pandemic there
were about a million monthly Crossing in
those directions with the April 2020
restrictions on Crossing at checkpoints
the number of monthly process fell to
2000 and was no longer back to the
previous level until the full-scale
Russian invasion and these facts
demonstrate the problematic nature of
counting the actual number of adps As
registration does not always indicate a
person's actual presence in the
territory controlled by Ukrainian
government
foreign
you see the main vectors of external
Force migration from Ukraine after the
start depression aggression in the 2015
the key problem is external migration
was that in most cases uraniums left as
labor migrants the countries of irido
did not Grant Refugee status in most
cases as a small part of the territory
of Ukraine was covered by the it was the
main argument and ukrainians themselves
have not sought Refuge status because of
significant restrictions on employment
and now I want to share some our
uh
some our uh ideas with which we found
during our interviews adapts interviews
people but before I start talking about
some groups of uh displaced population I
want to come back to this whole picture
which give us the opportunity what's
happened uh in Ukraine on this stage uh
in both migration report 2020 Ukraine
mentioned in the list of top 20
countries which are largest stock of
internally displaced person by conflict
and violence at the end of 2018. this is
the beginning of Russian aggression in
2014 more than 2 million people have
learned the uncontrolled territories of
Ukraine and the first to move both to
other parts of Ukraine and Beyond in
sports according to the ministry of
social policy after 2015 and before the
full-scale Russian invasion the number
of registered internally displaced
person was relatively stable at around
1.5 million residents of bottom
territories have also been free the
country uh other countries since 2014 as
of December 2015 in the countries that
have common borders with Ukraine such as
Russia Belarus Poland Slovakia
they were more than um it's mere four uh
400 000 ukrainians seeking refutures and
uh more than 700
000 ukrainians seeking other form of
legal stay in the mentioned countries
the estimated population of the occupied
territories of the United Local speeches
is 3.7 million there are mostly people
who formally Remain the citizen of
ukraines it's possible it's very
important group of population which uh
have not enough attention uh in many
researches and in many policies State
policies
since 2013
in all our research we have focused on
different groups of people affected by
War
first of all internally displaced person
persons with their own strategies of
migration and adaptation external
migrants who were first to move by the
war
uh then people residing in the occupied
territories who are witnessing a
transformation of their everyday lives
and residents of so-called presume the
Territory between the two conflict
parties beyond the jurisdictions and
therefore where no one was responsible
for their lives and will be of people
who lived here
in all these cases the focus won on the
people whose life growth have been
ruined and who have found themselves in
extreme circumstances or work forced
migration and or under the patients
together all these studies could be
referred to as the average person's life
under extreme circumstances in the
context of false is this our research a
range of social fundamental arise which
deserve careful attention since they
concern the recognition of people's
rights to full life and protection this
social phenomena includes stigmatization
social exclusion social deprivation
discrimination and uh practices of other
people residing in the territories and
gone by the war in 2014 received no
support from the government at the
beginning of the military economy a very
small number of people were evacuated
mostly by volunteer groups another
important point in their perception of
first displacement what the idps in the
context of Ukrainian State policy will
and are perceived as a homogeneous group
however this vision of idps does not
respond to the needs motivations and
behaviors of different segments of IDK
so we try to segment this group and look
on different segments of these B group
which are absolutely not homogeneous in
all reports of the situation of idps in
Ukraine is a group of people of
retirement age it's one segment receives
an enormous amount of attention it's
absolutely right the payment of Pensions
has been and remains problematic in the
solidary model that exists in Ukraine
for today pensions should be linked to
citizenship not to local budget and
social assistance but the problem was
that pensions in 2014 were tied to local
budget it's a very big problem in
resilience a pension in this situation
and because in the first wave
displacement caused by Russian
aggression in the 2014 people of
retirement age face the need to register
in Ukrainian government-controlled
territory and under uh undergo
accumulating identification procedures
every few months this has on the one
hand uh inflated the real number of idps
forcing people to uh picturesly
registered for receiving pensions and on
the other hand it has created a
situation in which people of retirement
age had to be identified in Ocean bomb
in Ukraine every several months had to
stand increase and risk their lives
undergoing humiliation and meaningless
identification identification procedures
in Ukrainian Banks and state
institutions I want to show you some
photos that I took during one of my
studies during my study trip these are
people who are line up to cross the
border between Ukrainian control and
non-government control parts of Logan's
published it's so-called zero point uh
and you see here how it's look like it's
usually yeah six people in one line and
very very low fees uh with people who
are waiting for these Crossings the
Border uh moreover it's uh other look on
the same position moreover in this
checkpoint people had to cross
unfortunately it's not my fault to play
those photos it was fine but this I use
in open sources to show you uh how it
was during long period now this broken
most are repaired uh moreover this year
when people had to cross over the
destroyed Bridge as you can see the
bridge as you can see on this slide uh
and uh
try to image it how how it was for
people uh
retirement age or elderly people it's
absolutely horrible situation for many
of them
uh this this policy of course this
policy I mean this policy of
identification process especially the
fact that elderly people these limited
Mobility
uh that end up being completely denied
access to pension Provisions it has been
estimated that the number of such people
aren't able to receive a pension in
2013-2015 was over half a million those
who dare to cross the demarcation line
for the identification procedure suffer
it as well research participants
estimate that crossing the borderline
could take anywhere
from several hours to hours to several
days you it's really long quiz it's
really much time you stay in this quiz
and maybe several what to do something
positive button so that it's clear
positive moment but we see how many
businesses uh arise around this
situation many people who come to these
people who stay in increase and propose
a different kind of help to buy foods to
stain in the line to uh
to sell a place in the quiz Etc so many
businesses very very interesting
business how it's organized here but
elderly people who died while passing
through the demarcation might contribute
to the statistic of Civilian videos the
exact number is unknown uh and there is
no systematic calculation of people who
died increased on both sides of the
location line
in a pandemic the checkpoints were
closed and remained partially closed
until the outbreak of the full-scale war
in this time the only one option was to
enter through the territory of Russian
Federation but in this case people must
pay a fine for illegally crossing the
world
the Ukrainian government softened this
measure and no fines were imposed
there's a full-scale Russian invasion
the scope of occupied territories has
increased today it is no longer just a
problem of Ukrainian citizens living
under occupation on the Crimean
Peninsula part of the United States it
is now also a problem for residents of
parts of your own characters of leisure
regions while the procedure for a
growing pension has been simplified with
a bank card it is automatically extended
and money is transferred to the account
but the problem for pensioners in the
occupied territory Remains the uh
inability to receive this money the
Russian Federation is working Ukrainian
mobile communication and uh restricting
access to Ukrainian websites and
services via the Internet for residents
of the occupied territories even if they
have a bank card with money transferred
to it there is no place to cash it and
it is not possible to pay with it by 4
in shops Etc as a result people as they
have to find ways to travel to Ukraine
government control areas which is
difficult to do given the hostilities or
turn to Illegal money changers Changers
and loss a significant percentage of
their transfers
in parallels the banks ensure that there
are no long interruptions in the use of
the Earth at least six months as this
could indicate the possible death of the
beneficiary of their punch in such a
case payments are suspended until the
circumstances are clarified
however for the real elderly person the
bureaucratic formula of clarification
means finding difficult ways to travel
to the control territory and the risk of
death
as of today
as of today
after a few discussion about the
possibility of paying attention to
so-called collaborators seem to have a
subside the Ukrainian State demonstrates
maximum reality in their uh accrual of
Pensions to those who have earned it
according to the solidarity function
system in Ukraine wherever these people
are located
after early
um and be the statement about the
population of the occupied territory
government officials now clearly
articulate the peoples as the state's
primary value however the reality of war
and a lot of effective mechanisms
receiving payment
where all options are blocked by their
present remaining problem its importance
lies in the fact that for people in the
occupied territories is it is often a
question of survival which affects how
they evaluate the ability of their own
state to protect them
this difference in situation and policy
in the first and second stage of Russian
aggression because the current policy of
Ukrainian State and Society towards the
victims of the first day of Russian
aggression considerably more human and
less discriminatory in nature was the
result of the struggle for their rights
by the first idps and a complicated uh
this complicated public debates in the
country
but uh let's back to the situation in
2014 another group seriously affected by
their conflict was people of
pre-retirement age people from this
category had little chance of employment
in Ukraine have this very big problem of
Ages discrimination uh and
um therefore they find themselves in an
extremely low situation as a result of
first uh displacement the amount of
state aid for uh ill
capacitated person was one thousand
grimness it's near 25 dollars monthly
and uh
442 greenness it's near 20 30 dollars
it's for your company's monthly for
those who are able to work it's very
small
so it's very very small amount such
payments could not even cover basic food
expenses uh and they are of course not
enough to rent house moreover this
category of people have been completely
invisible for most of the international
organization that help people affected
by work in the National Organization
mostly work with Target group on this
stage such as retired people people with
disabilities motherless little children
a large family but this group of people
have absolutely lack of help
uh and this group remained ignored by
International Organization also this
category was also without help and stay
invisible
then under these conditions uh of
divided votes and separated families
there are uh unwarned deaths that are
rarely described in academic literature
before the full-scale Russian invasion
the average person to enter the Empire
territory should send a request to the
security service of Ukraine and receive
within 10 days a permit for border
crossing important life events the task
of illness of reality of a family
reunion could accelerate this procedure
also one still has no spend time
providing official confirmation of Life
events also a decision to let someone
cross the line was made
um arbitrarily by a certain military
person at the checkpoint on any side of
the demarcation line the pandemic have
worsened this problem people were being
denied they arrive to close the border
even when they could confirm purposes of
important life events the psychological
traumas of the dances of loved ones who
are separated by long distance and
unborn deaths are hard to assess the
interviews I conduct shows that in the
occupied territory neighbors got
together to very elderly people who
lived alone and their children never saw
their parents death
ordinary people who have found
themselves in extreme circumstances
somehow to try to restore the normality
of their life at the same time they face
certain barriers both at the level of
reaction in the society and at the
institutional level in totally displaced
person were limited in their rights all
Ukrainian IDP have been deprived of the
rights to vote on local government
elections until 2020 idps from Crimea I
still Define a non-residence by the
country's bank system and have limited
access to banking services prior to the
full-scale aggressions those IDP who
were expecting to receive state
assistance head to undergo additional
humiliating procedures or identification
and provide detailed personal
information including answering
questions about the reality to Ukrainian
State I signed such documentary very
well remember how it is uh which
ultimately creates a feeling of their
inferior systems
the awareness of all this problem and
the active presence of ADP in public
debates give rise to many new processes
in Ukrainian Society for example the
demand of medical service
um from more than a million people has a
simultaneously led to an accelerated
reform of ukrainian's medical system
today's medical system is no longer tied
to the place of illustration of
Ukrainian Citizen and medical service
are available everywhere in the country
the struggle for the political rights of
ADP has led to the restoration of the
right to vote not only in presidential
and parliamentary election but also in
local election in 2020. in the Ukrainian
context of War enforce migration we see
many hybrid volunteering practices and
strategies some of which grow into
stable and formalized activities and
some of which Fade Away both because of
mitigation and because of Pearl out of
many people who very actively involved
in this volunteering activity because
this boss one had to have a very active
person who do everything now in
Ukrainian Society but many of them faces
this problem however most organized and
spontaneous individual volunteering
activities have a significant impact on
the society for example the volunteer
psychologist who actively help people to
overcome stress on the matter in 2014
have seen a change in people's attitude
towards their own mental health and
towards Professionals in this field and
really now have a very big change in
Ukrainian society when people start
looking under their mental health start
thinking about what to do in their
mental health how how to change our
system medical system and given access
to different Services which are
connected to this new concept of mental
health in Ukraine it's really very very
important change in the society for
example in one our research and we have
most part it was a quantitative
qualitative part of this research about
different kind of practices connected to
the mental health and we ask our
participants about how how they try to
solve their problem if they feel
something goes wrong what they do and
only 2.8 persons of our respondents says
that they come to the professionals and
ask about help in the mental health
issues uh it's very low level it's
really very very low level of uh
working under this issue but on the
other hand we see that this situation
accelerate this development and people
start thinking about this it starts
during the maidan era it was very
important when people see that uh it's
very difficult for them to perceive the
education to live in this situation and
many psychologies come to the maidan
like a volunteers and start give this
the help but to people and these
um
accelerate these change in the culture
of mental health or working on the
mental skills issue
then
um
let me say several quotes about this
before this
you say several words about volunteering
practices because I think it's a very
important it's a very important change
in Ukrainian society and the uh it's led
us to present situation
I was a pivotal moment that a
straightened solidarity demand
ukrainians well some sort sectors groups
demonstrated a transfer of Social and
human capital to the situation of mass
mass displacement I talk about warranty
and first of all in this field of the
this helping displaced persons many
organizations active today in providing
help to idps were created at the very
beginning of the conflict based on
spontaneous health and many idps were
involved with these processes many idb
script create this volunteering groups
reach our health to idps in this
situation for instance
Source was founded in 2014 as a hotline
used for quick coordination of Health to
the injured people today's organization
and uh you might five coordinators and
around 40 volunteers of the Court line
also there is a network of regional
Volunteers in the natural gas and uh 15
more regions of Ukraine the other
organization station of car Q uh got its
name because of the specificity of its
work it was at the railway station where
the volunteers were meeting people who
run away from the national program
spiritually affected by War and we're
helping these clothes food a city for
accumulation and providing legal
consultation for people forced to
rapidly leave their homes for their
indefinite time could help just in the
period from June till December 2014
station cartoon managed to find the
places for residents for 30 000 of the
displays people a survey of
Representatives of
138 in Euros we mainly surely
incorporation this
research about mental health it's the
same situation it had a common project
with Birmingham University
and Ukrainian Catholic University and uh
in this research we uh talk with 138
representatives of ngos in Ukraine and
we see that
they talk that many people who ask about
help receive the following Services as
you can see here it's consultation
regarding employment into one person
psychological support as you see these a
very big number of people who receive
this but usually idps uh not ask about
this help first you need to propose
these Services if you want to involve
people in such communication then
arrangement of the free time 67 percent
assistant in the renewal of payment of
five months of pensioners and help with
finding the place of residence in most
cases ngos and volunteers were first to
deal with the multi-side case management
uh as a root people who addressed for
help had a birth of the whole set of
problems that couldn't be solved
separately for instance the Lost
document events cause the restrictions
in the siege of accommodation and
employment and the non-payment of
Pensions for many months especially in
the situation of the single elderly
people causes the impossibility to pay
for that pay it is important to note
that the increase in mutual systems is
observed not only in the south east
European near the area of military
actions but also in the other regions
the complex and flexible volunteers
involves good logistic and management
Builds on trust and informal connections
makes Youth Sports sponsorship funding
and its publicly owe uh this widespread
involvement of people in um charitable
activities creates a feeling of
Engagement and solidarity that is
crucial during the war and despite
displacement
the needs to cooperate this business
structure in one way or another forms a
complex interaction between them and
flexible volunteer structure which often
creates profitable partnership
businesses in most cases there are small
or medium-signed businesses specific of
this communication because large
businesses usually work these they are
Charities but small uh and middle
businesses very actively communicate
with volunteers see volunteers group as
a professionals to whom they can entrust
and delegate social work and Trust as
the basis of this relationship in terms
encourage volunteers to worry about
their reputational capital and strive to
make their activities as open as
possible it's very important processes
and in the context of social upheaval
and awareness of the states considerable
uh LED in the response professionals who
entered volunteering often so it is an
alternative to the um unwidal stage
Machinery as an opportunity to implement
projects that they could not Implement
within the already existing structure in
this case you can speak of the powerful
Reformatory potential of the volunteer
movement which uh through its activity
shapes new model of behavior and creates
orientation patterns and values
overall it provides a better
understanding of the mechanism of
horizontal mobilization in Ukraine
society and the conditions of full-scale
war and that unique situation of
interaction between volunteer groups and
South sector business and state
structure and
um
as you can see Iranian society and
representatives of State structure have
learned from the situation in Ukrainian
society as a result of this first stage
of this first wave Russian aggression in
most cases there are quite complex
processes that deal with issue of
identity awareness of urban self as a
political nation and the development of
a new language for speaking about what
is going on around us how about the
situation of Ukrainian visibility of
having a position that sums in different
languages is a result of discussion and
experience of these first eight-year
period of this Russian aggression
because it was the experience of
volunteering during this period that
allowed the volunteer movement in
Ukraine in the face of full-scale War to
mobilize not in days but in hours and
start talking to defend the country and
support the population uh and they are
the policy was IDP celebrate who Fleet
as a result of the February 2022 phase
of the war used best practices regarding
idps that were formed during eight years
and be aware of the areas that were the
most problematic regarding the response
to the IDP leads
the areas where the response was less
efficient include the lack of affordable
and accessible accommodation and the
lack of social housing we still have
this problem in our country issues with
pension and benefits
the lack of recognition of the benefits
of mental health support stigmatization
of mental health and the lack of
accessible mental health support issues
with the employment of people of
pre-retirement age
and given that globally that number of
ADP increased from amount
70 million in 1998 to
59.1 million in 2021 and that many
researchers experience protracted
internal displacement before Crossing
international border the lessons from
Ukraine can be available in addressing
similar challenges in different contexts
thank you so much
foreign
I teach foreign policy at University of
Haven uh thank you so much for being
here and for all your work I know it
took a lot of risk on your partner
um I was wondering if you knew What
proportion of idps have acquired
multiple identifications like Russian
passports or DNR lnr passports because
right now you know there's a movement to
terminate Ukrainian citizenship of
individuals that are found to have
multiple identities or multiple
potentials that way um in particular the
case with
that we just recently disclosed so
there's a move in Ukraine to you know
quickly terminate this whole
constitutional this process for that but
I was wondering if you um if that was
part of your research and if you know
proportionally how many of idps have
actually managed to have Russian
passports and DNR and if it hurts them
right now as they you know rebuild their
lives thank you very much for this
question it's really very important to
understand what's so so going on on
these occupied territories as I know the
last Data before the full-scale
regression it was
um 700 000 people who take Russian
passport uh but unfortunately I don't
know proportion because I usually use
and apps interview it's not for
proportions but what I know about this
situation uh it's not absolutely not a
surprise for many people who are uh deal
with this issue like idps you know it's
on the case of Crimea Peninsula you need
two passports you need two passports
because uh without these two passport
you have not any opportunity to go
across the border in the same situation
on occupied territory and what is a
little bit problematic for the future
from my employer to infuse the people on
this territory have an opportunity to
have five or six passports uh how it's
work in Ukrainian context first of all
it's your National Ukrainian passport
then we officially have a right to have
two International passports this is
three password foreign
you have to renounce you are one of your
citizens yes of course but so we are
talking about real practices
and they all have these six passports
and use in different contexts they use
different passports uh why I think it's
a very important knowledgeable if you'd
be specific because it's it's a task for
the future how to love with these people
who have this different type of passport
but in this case we talk about
absolutely about absolutely rational uh
acts of these people but uh if you ask
about identity it's more complicated and
it's my pleasure I uh after my
presentation I I will share my text
rewrite this Oksana Shadow come some of
the text about a dynamic of Ukrainian
identities and it's it's available
conversation because we have a different
combination and we write only about
nationality not only and not about the
whole hierarchy of either only about
ethnic and national identity they have
here so many problems when people for
example ask about their nationality if
Ukraine they usually don't know what
they mean they talk about citizenship or
they talk about ethnicity because we
received this problem from the Soviet
space when uh it was a prescription
statuses and in this case
then someone from Ukraine says um
ukrainians you you are not you don't
know what they what the person means
it's about ethnicity it's about
citizenship
we write about everything in details and
you'll be happy to share this it's
really very interesting to look on this
dynamic because uh if we use a
quantitative data uh it's look very
optimistic that we have so many people
who are ukrainians but when we start
talking about uh the real identity how
they construct the event which is
absolutely as a future so we found a
very very good way how to ask people
about this uh first of all we ask them
uh are you thinking about uh you in the
ethnic or national coordinates and many
says yes many people says yes only a
small group says no I don't want to talk
about me like
with official discourses but they live
in situation of uh self-limitation cell
censorship and why they avoid this
answer about the ethnicity it's very
interesting to this small group but very
interesting and uh other groups when we
talk on the numbers it looks very
optimistic but how do you ask we ask
first of all how you identifying
yourself like ethnic or a citizen Etc
and after that when person uses
something if I ask you who are you my
nationality and person says I'm
Ukrainian the Russian or Russian Etc and
how does it asks what it's mean for you
and starting from this point persons
will start create this
very interesting concept of being a
national identity and after that we try
to systematize all these
um version of national identities in
it's really very interesting but when
you read everything means or you
understand that it's not so easy like
it's look like when we ask only about
nationality
thank you
political science here so my question
actually Builds on this which is about
the use of language so what languages do
they use and uh not just by the internal
space persons but by the officials or
like by the by both by the volunteers
and like the state officials
you asked me about language as a country
or about language for research
uh as it says we really now perceive a
very rapid euclidization in the country
and uh it's really a way how to separate
how to identify the
uh not others but us in this case but
while it's important for example I come
back to this idea that I work not with
numbers but I will be successes when I
talk with people and it was very
interesting for me but I thought this
one of my interlocutor about this issue
how he perceives a russian-speaking
people now uh in the context of skill
aggression and she says me uh that it's
very important for him that person start
from something from small sentences in
Ukrainian language because he needs
these four uh this identification
processes and after that they know that
these persons are ours it's not others
and after that many people start talking
Russian language uh but now many of them
try to tell the language of Ukrainian
but it usually take time it's usually
takes time it's not possible to start
talking in uh other languages but all
ukrainians are available we have not in
Ukraine people who know only one
language all ukrainians bilingual it's a
question of practices or some part of
you can have practices to use Russian uh
everyday life some other part of
ukrainians very actively use Ukrainian
in everyday life but in our interview we
see a very interesting moment which show
how uh these uh protests started after
2013 for example I have an interview
with a person who are voluntarily joined
to military information on the territory
of the Nets control gun scope list and
when I asked him about the language user
she says it's very important how he
promulgative unfortunately Rush
his unfortunately shows you the
perception of the situation and wishes
to to use the language and other uh in
2018 uh I conducted a research in all
four or blessed of Ukraine from Logan's
Commerce and the police
now you see it it's a battlefield in
Ukraine and of course we ask about
identity and we ask about uh um language
using usage and what I uh found during
this research uh unfortunately uh it's
not possible to quickly file this scheme
but if I'm not mistake uh when I ask
about these people who live in the
NetSpend began School bless uh more than
it's near 40 percent of them says that
the native language
is uh Ukraine but when I ask what
language use of the work what language
you use in everyday communication it's
usually much more Russian language and
but here we see a desire to be Ukrainian
speakers
sorry what about the children are they
taught in uh bilingual from an early age
the curriculum is by people especially
children especially young person because
during 30 years in Ukraine we have this
soft realization and for example uh
before 2014 in my native City
International
I read a letter on the independent
language and all our curriculum was in
Ukrainian and it was a state policy and
why Young Generation who studied in
Ukrainian schools and studying Ukrainian
University
um have a good practices to use
Ukrainian languages for many young
people in Ukraine it's more important to
to Siege from from the Ukrainian to
Russian but not not now it was
unfortunately Russia here because it's a
political reaction now many ukrainians
know Russian very well but now they stop
users language if they could to change
the language
so there's no coercion of the part of
the operation state
so those that you observe are the ones
from Distributing the policy benefits
so was there a pressure to use Ukrainian
persons
you know I think it's a part of maybe
this propagandistic discourses it's it's
not the pressure
and it's a process as well you need to
integrate this normal communication in
the state I think it's a conversation
about the right of people to talk in the
native language and for many ukrainians
Ukrainian native language but we during
long time we live in russian-speaking
environment
and I think now in my country we have
these very important discussion between
uh these two different uh speaking
groups in Ukraine how to uh how to have
this compromise
and according to the understanding of
the right of security
and I think the ball push everybody
declared to to start use the email in
everyday life
maybe I'll just ask one question then if
I take advantage of my position since we
have a couple more minutes so you had
also talked with progression
people in the in the donbass years ago
and with with the rebels what did you
learn what did you understand about
their position from having spoken with
them
this is the point of view that's so hard
for us to get and even now I was
pleading with um my friend Pavel from
youngjek who is a young polish
journalist who covered the war in the
dumbass and now he's covering it again
he's very good at talking to people he's
like this young polish guy
um and I said Pavel can't you get
interviews with Russian soldiers like
can't like if they're going to talk to
anyone if anyone you and he's like now
even I can't do it I just can't talk to
them
um but what did you learn about how
people were thinking thank you very much
for this fashion it's very complicated
question for me I study a lot but I have
a lot of answers
clear and simple answer to this question
is motivation for example people who
voluntarily join these military
formation uh from societal DPR and LPR
and it was it was horrible research for
me because I need to talk with people
who are my enemy and then I try to to
analyze the motivation and trying to
understand but what uh what's their
motivation why they join these military
information from other side but I think
it's it's really very very important to
understand that uh here it's not
possible to have a simple answer to this
question and many of them have a long
life strategy many of them was
unsuccessful during this life and these
uh forms the uh maybe negative
perception of Ukrainian statehood which
resulted them in the insurance then I
work with them this flows of information
and how people perceive the information
it's
all historians know how it's work it's
it's a very simple uh for understanding
of this for example during this initial
stage in 2014 and 2015 or people who
live on the territory of deeper and
Emperor have a free access to Internet
but when you have this free access to
Internet why you not diversify the
information by by you
um don't read the other sources no many
people don't read and how it's work it's
usually work in a very simple way you
start to read some text and see that
it's opposite to you you you will not
agree with this test and you close this
resources and start uh see to the other
sources which are very close to your
perception of the real situation and
after that we see how these audience
encapsulated uh during this stage and
the distance between them become a very
big and they are oriented to absolutely
other model of perceptional situation
Model Behavior Etc it's so many reasons
so so many reasons and we see from the
point of view the childhood from from
the point of view are they a successful
when they start the education for
example it was very interesting for me
many of our interlocutors from their
style side of the conflict
um to says about the educational
strategy like a very specific for
example it's combination of radio
technique and culturology
it's the first and try to find uh
themselves in a few different spheres
and in the results have not any good
results before you know they are
successful uh life for example on this
speech it's really so so many so many
moments which are important to
understanding how this works
research from the refugee study center
in Oxford in the UK
um I wanted to ask because you were
talking a bit about young younger people
who were choosing not to
um
take ibp status I think you said because
of some stigma
um or not wanting to speak about on the
state I wondered if you could explain a
bit more about why they felt that that
status was something stigmatized
um and also about what they do instead
you know like how they would identify
instead or what kind of
um how they would go about like making
themselves
foreign
PS which are very interesting to
understand and why they choose such
strategies when they relocated many
young people uh and I think it's a main
difference between young and older
generation mainly young people have an
experience how to rent the house
before the forced communication and they
not be afraid of the future in this case
they come from don't ask the
contribution to keep and start their new
career but why they uh why why we talk
about this strategy how to avoid the
stigmatization because in the beginning
of the conflict uh many people in
Ukraine
um don't understand really what's
happened and I talk about this that this
situation on the state level called like
Auto anti-terreleistic operation and
it's created with a specific situation
in society when uh IDP is perceived like
collaborators like people who are invite
Russian soldiers so to Ukrainian land
etc etc and why young people have this
opportunity and try to avoid to receive
these IDP statuses because of these
ambiguous perception in this Society
um oh it's really was much more easy for
them because they have this previous
experience how to leave his own parents
how much than the houses and why they
try to and well many many idps receive
these documentables IDP statuses uh then
they need to have this help from the
states they stayed from the states uh
but then uh it's become
um
it's the next stage uh all of us need to
have this document that we have a status
of idps because of other reasons for
example uh when I try to do something in
official way my passport it is not
enough for solving many problems I need
to have these additional documents about
my IDP statuses but now it's totally
change now our state talk about these
canceling of IDP stocks at all but on
the other hand we need we still need
these statuses because it's still about
the help of people who are perceived the
world who need these State help
it seems expression of discussion in
Ukrainian Society how to be resist
status but it's me now over to the amidp
and how to deal with establishing
Ukrainian Society
hi my name is Caroline I'm a second year
Master's student in the European
International Studies program
um I have a question about the
perception of ukrainians abroad
um at least um well I I was in I was in
Poland over the summer helping out at a
reception point for a refugees from
Ukraine and um
uh you know I've been in Keys before and
you know you you saw in the just like
anecdotally on the Metro uh in the cute
Metra you'd see all these signs but
it's blend and um someone told me before
I came to Poland that has a rule at
least before
the war a lot of Uber drivers in Poland
were Ukrainian men and that then when
the uh on the full scale aggression
began and that people left that that was
uh it created I got a shift in
um sort of like demographically in
Poland who was working he was not
um what is uh have you seen any like in
terms of and then at least some like uh
and then just walking around the
significant outpouring of support for
um for Ukrainian refugees and how people
put aside
um businesses
um like their you know livelihoods to
develop significant portions of their
time to helping people coming in
um what if you
um
at least noticed in terms of the
evolution of perceptions of ukrainians
abroad or
daughter thank you
it's about current situation thank you
very much
um I know much more about the situation
in Germany because I believe in Germany
and helped many many refugees from
Ukraine during this period and they
actually involved in this volunteer
procedures in in drama you know how it's
organized and how it's working Germany
um perception rather positive and of
course in Poland too uh for me was an
expected level of sports from problem
Society it's really very high level of
support and uh you need to know that
it's not States first of all support on
the level of the society other Society
uh punish people are very actively
reacted to the situation uh it's my
personal situation uh in the day when a
full skin was started I wasn't living
with my youngest son and I went uh my
feet across the border from uh shege
needs almost to to Poland it was the
first night after the starting a
full-scale war and uh people from Poland
waiting for us
on the Polish side of the Border
it's first night
we come to the border and pick up people
and help in with any question
I think it's it's a very high level
sport it's really very hard it still
exists in Polish Society they actively
involved of course we still could face
with some negative perception which we
inhabited from the parents period but
it's something very human we usually
have a different people who reacted in
different things but if you look on this
situation at all I think we have
unprecedented lot of health and support
in Europe
much
six foot presentation um I have a
question in terms of the uh joining
joining the RMA speechers our younger
second of the idps right uh in terms of
comparison between the younger segment
of IDP and the rest of the young people
in Ukraine join in the war after 2014 or
during the joining our army after 24-14
and also like more recently do you see
some sort of variation in terms of for
example bureaucratic herdos product to
join the Army because of the identity of
various sorts of wars and secondly is
also what Slayer intrinsic motivation in
terms of serving the state right and
have you seen any evidence or insight
about it unfortunately I have not a new
research about this and so it's maybe
only my
my feeling of my understanding of this
moment so uh
and we work with this motivation in 2013
because we have these two groups on one
side of the people who support this DPR
number and on the other side it was the
opinion volunteers and um it was really
very interesting to look on this
motivation and many of them who
voluntarily involved in such fighting
regain this enemy in on this first stage
of the book uh have a very
clear
description of the identity what they
mean when I start talking about this
well what I mean uh in this case when
you are not sure in your identity uh uh
but I ask you about your identity you
start a very long and very detailed uh
description how it's possible to
identify view in different situations
Etc if people show in the identity it's
usually very clear and very simple
answer I'm Ukrainian I'm citizen of
Ukraine it's my country it's my duty
it was very interesting to compile this
description of identity from these
people who support people and people who
join these Ukrainian volunteer
information and I think the same
situation might be now in present day
when uh many uh young men and not young
only and not only men in Ukraine
voluntarily join army and I think it's a
very strong motivation which are
connected with so these model of quality
definition I talk about these today and
they think now Ukraine is really
perceive themselves like political
Nation it's a very very important role
and so all ukrainians understand that we
are talking about our future in this
situation that's our duty to save our
future and uh I think it's a very very
strong and Main motivation for for many
of our people who now join army people
oh so you um join me
um I wanna I wanna say Professor mcavo I
think there's still food out there so
I'm going to do my Jewish mother thing
and encourage everyone to eat their
protein and vegetables
um briefly it responds to your question
and for the non-slav assist here there's
a novel that recently has been
translated to English by one of uh
oksana's one of the colleagues on the
living room from Donetsk that he he was
an internally displaced person he moved
in 2014.
a great novelist who has been writing in
Russian learned Ukrainian and wrote this
novel one degree about the experience of
being a displaced person you know and
reconstructing you know a self in a
language that was his but wasn't quite
his
um and was wonderfully translated into
English by my colleague Mark Andre Mark
Andre chick at Columbia and has just
come out so I just wanted to if you want
to commune with that experience you know
from the point of view of literary
fiction
um I encourage you to do that
um students please feel free to hang
around and talk to Professor Mike she's
very friendly and
please join me in thanking her
foreign